madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce mardi 20 juillet le
tour de france espanoles kart'in
s'envole dans les pyrénées mais
l'américain armstrong s'accroche il
finit quatrième et reste en jaune avec
maintenant toutes les chances de
l'emporter à paris armstrong dont le
monde révèle aujourd'hui qu'on a trouvée
dans ses urines quelques traces de
corticoïdes l'autre armstrong mais il a
été décoré aujourd'hui par le
vice-président américain 30 ans jour
pour jour après ses premiers pas sur la
lune et sa phrase restée célèbre
un petit pas pour l'homme un grand pas
pour l'humanité dans ce journal nous
évoquerons ce qui reste bien sûr comme
l'une des plus belles épopées de ce
siècle
hinault joindront à toulouse patrick
baudry le parlement européen se choisit
une femme pour présidente nicole
fontaine a été élu dès le premier tour
une européenne convaincue qui succède
vingt ans après à simone veil un puzzle
macabre tour d'alfredo stranieri suspect
numéro 1 après la découverte de deux
corps dans le jardin d'une auberge en
aveyron hier deux autres cadavres ont
été déterrés dans la région parisienne
et puis notre regard sur la mode avec
les collections automne hiver et deux
défilés de choix ceux de dior et de la
croix la première étape des pyrénées
s'annonce et passionnante elle l'a été
après une succession d'attaqués
l'espagnolette carte il s'est envolé
vers la victoire il revient à la
deuxième place du classement général
mais c'est bien l'américain lance
armstrong qui garde le maillot jaune et
apparaît désormais comme le probable
vainqueur du tour 99
florent gautreau et philippe dès lors
c'est la revanche du coureur aux jambes
arquées le jour de gloire d'un homme de
l'ombre escardines l'habitude des places
d'honneur s'échappe dans le col de val
louron le cinquième col d'une terrible
journée dans les pyrénées
au sommet il possède plus d'une minute
d'avancé ses poursuivants ne le
reverront plus
derrière un de tongs accélère vie ronde
décidément moins fort qu'avant et lâché
seul bull parvient à suivre en amérique
le maillot jaune toujours plus fort que
ses rivaux à contrôler la course
mais pas question de dire que c'était
facile ce fut une dure journée très très
dur et j'ai apprécié le soutien de mes
coéquipiers en particulier de tyler
hamilton c'était du bon travail dans la
montée finale vers piau engaly richard
virenque est revenu sur amstrad dessus
le virenque voulait gagner dans les
pyrénées il avait promis d'attaquer
alors ils attaquent mais est-ce carte il
est déjà trop loin
l'espagnol qui a deux minutes d'avancé
va remporter la plus belle victoire de
sa carrière
il en profite pour s'installer à la
deuxième place du classement général
derrière lui du le souffle la 2e place à
vire entre le varois n'a pas gagné mais
il est satisfait l'important c'était de
revenir devant et ben on savait pour la
gagne après ça se joue pas beaucoup donc
salon ce qui est important c'est le
final et c'était montre aujourd'hui que
j'étais pas encore man armstrong
quatrième de l'étape a franchi le
premier obstacle pyrénéen sans encombre
il a désormais six minutes et 19
secondes d'avancé sur le deuxième au
classement général et le deuxième
c'était ce quartier le grimpeur le plus
discret du peloton n'avait jamais fait
autant parler de lui et demain avant de
quitter les pyrénées les coureurs
s'attaqueront à la légendaire montée du
tourmalet lance armstrong apparaît donc
plus que jamais comme le favori de
l'édition 99 armstrong le miraculé le
coureur propre qui a triomphé d'un
cancer avant de revenir au plus haut
niveau de la compétition il ya dans une
conférence de presse il affirmait encore
ne s'être jamais dopé
et pourtant d'après le journal le monde
ce sont bien des traces de corticoïdes
qu'on a retrouvée dans ses urines
nathanel de rinxent et alain poirier en
matière de dopage lance amstrong n'a
rien à cacher depuis le début du tour
l'américain était contrôlé à dix
reprises
officiellement tous les résultats sont
négatifs mais selon le monde paru
aujourd'hui des traces de corticoïdes
ont été décelées lors du contrôle
antidopage effectué à l'issue de la
première étape
vous confirmez vous n'avez pas pris de
médicaments depuis 96 c'est la vérité
vous n'avez pas pris de corticoïdes non
plus durant cette période je vous le
répète c'est la première voiture pour
parler les traces de corticoïdes
décelées dans les urines de l'américain
sont très nettement en dessous du seuil
de positivité pour les dirigeants de l'
us postal
l'un samsung n'a rien à se reprocher
d'ailleurs la presse je devrais même
pour parler crois que si un laboratoire
communique l'information de l'intéressé
nous sommes le premier intéressé alors
je ne sais pas pourquoi la presse est au
courant et nous pas donc c'est une
formation qui sait c'est une information
que je connais pas et qui met tant du
côté de lui si personne ne veut
commenter les résultats des examens
effectués par le laboratoire de châtenay
malabry
ça me choquerait mg j
est ce secret médical qui empêche le
seuil est de révéler que depuis le début
du tour sur la centaine d'échantillons
analysés 20 à 30 cas présenterait des
traces de corticoïdes christophe rinero
fait partie de ceux là mais il a une
explication non je crois que je suis pas
positif puisque voilà j'ai un certificat
médical
peut-être dans la mentalité des gens
n'est jaloux avant de dire rinero à user
de à jouer avec les corticoïdes pour
pour les rêves pour faire des résultats
pour améliorer mes performances mais bon
j'ai pas usa ça pour mes performances
aujourd'hui si les contrôles sont de
plus en plus efficaces face aux
corticoïdes
en revanche les informations ont du mal
à circuler
on est loin de la transparence prônées
par l'uci au début du tour il a bien
fallu se rendre à l'évidence tour à tour
la famille de john kennedy junior celle
de son épouse et de sa belle-soeur ont
annoncé officiellement la mort de leurs
proches les recherches se poursuivent au
large de yanis porte pour tenter de
retrouver et leurs corps et les débris
de l'appareil
mais tout espoir a maintenant dix parcs
reportage de pascal douce est bon il est
doit repérer l'endroit est dédié au père
qui aimait tant à yanis porte mais c'est
là cantié sont venus pour le fils
honorer l'un de ces rendez-vous
spontanée de l'amérique avec son
histoire
les enfants ils font connaissance avec
la mémoire collective
ce soir par exemple le petit luc n'aime
peut être plus tellement les avions leur
présence à tous ici est un acte
spirituel et patriotique
j'ai le même âge que lui dit cet homme
c'est comme si j'avais grandi avec lui
c'est un membre de la grande famille
américaine elle vient d'arizona
elle explique qu'elle devait passer ses
vacances à new york mais qu'en apprenant
la nouvelle à la télévision elle ne
pouvait que venir ici difficile de
rester indifférent à l'événement les
touristes français ont eux aussi fait le
voyage fait le détour spécialement
aujourd'hui en raison des circonstances
on a voulu marquer notre sympathie
un passant l'a r venant au mémorial
entrée gratuite aujourd'hui au musée
tout proche dédié à john fitzgerald
kennedy john john il jouait jusqu'à
présent le rôle du parfait petit
bonhomme des années 60 les gardiens du
temple lui réserveront une autre place
désormais le lieu symbole des vacances
dorées du chouchou de l'amérique doit
respecter le deuil
plus que partout ailleurs aux états unis
rien exporté depuis plus d'un demi
siècle le havre de paix de la famille
kennedy pour la plus grande fierté des
gens d'ici meriane nice porte sera aussi
désormais associé à tout jamais à la
mort de john john et les habitants se
serait bien passé de cette légende la
même s'il enquête sur les circonstances
de l'accident doit durer plusieurs mois
on en sait maintenant un peu plus sur
les conditions dans lesquelles l'avion
piloté par john kennedy le piper
saratoga s'est abîmé en mer une chute
brutale vertigineuse de plus de 13 cents
mètres à la minute qui tient sans doute
autant aux conditions météo quelques
expériences du pilote ce soir des
plongeurs devaient repartir à la
recherche de l'épave c'est ce qu'on voit
sur ces images et nous allons voir
maintenant le reportage de fabrice
hausse est de philippe lauzier nous
sommes dans le cockpit d'un piper pa28
le petit frère du saratoga l'avion dans
lequel john kennedy junior a disparu le
pea 28 est américain il n'embarque
quatre passagers contre 6 pour le
saratoga le tableau de bord et les
principes de pilotage sont en tout point
identique john-john avec une centaine
d'heures de vol et connaissaient mal son
avion selon jean-marc un pilote
expérimenté ce manque de pratique a peut
être conduit à une erreur de pilotage
ce qui est plus plate et éventuellement
une perte de référence visuelle voyez là
on a un horizon bien défini si je
commence à dire et je m'en rends compte
vous imaginez qu'on serait dans des
nuages et ben on a plus que cet
instrument là quel horizon artificiel
pour se repérer et si on n'était pas
habitué bar on sait pas s'en servir en
pure perte des références 106 références
visuelles john kennedy a peut-être
paniqué il n'a pas su utiliser les
instruments de bord une aide technique
pourtant indispensable dès que le temps
se fait menaçant vendredi soir les
conditions sont mauvaises
l'avion des kennedy chute de 333 m en 14
secondes
autre élément qui renforce la thèse
d'une erreur de pilotage l'absence de
tout message radio voyait de l'avion en
détresse
qu'est ce que font tous les pilotes
qu'on est arrivé à un problème moteur de
façon à prévenir et de lancer les
secours
il l'a pas fait ce qui laisse un peu
près l'âge et qui s'est passé autre
chose qu'une défaillance mécanique
mais la faute de pilotage n'est malgré
tout une hypothèse elle pourrait bien
rester car le piper saratoga est
dépourvu de boîtes noires harkat
priorité libéral en floride les
astronautes de la navette columbia on
tue quelques sueurs froides quand le
décompte a été brutalement stoppé six
secondes seulement avant le tir la nuit
dernière en cause un niveau trop élevé
d'hydrogène dans l'accompagnement
arrière du moteur
en fait après analyse il semble bien
qu'il s'agissait d'une fausse alerte le
lancement a été reporté de deux jours
comme mbia dont le commandant de bord
pour la première fois est une femme
compte parmi son équipage vous le savez
un français michel tonini ce vol devait
pourtant qu un incident et avec
l'anniversaire de la mission apollon
c'était un 20 juillet hors de new york 1
21 juillet européenne neil armstrong
posait pour la première fois le pied sur
la lune devant plus de 500 millions de
téléspectateurs et bay l'aboutissement
d'une course implacable entre russes et
américains et surtout la concrétisation
d'un des plus beaux rêves de l'humanité
patrice paie pour ce vol qui doit
conduire le premier homme sur la lune la
nasa a choisi trois hommes d'expérience
tous ont déjà effectué un vol dans
l'espace mais aux âmes score est désigné
comme chef de la mission
il a 39 ans il est ingénieur en
aéronautique elles bonne pause buzz
aldrin pilotera le module lunaire
il est diplômé de wight pointe
michael collins sera responsable du
module de commande
c'est le sacrifier de la mission il ne
marchera pas sur la lune
16 juillet 69 la saturn 5 s'arrache du
pas de tir de cap canaveral
plus d'un million de spectateurs
assistent à ce départ historique
la saturn 5 la fusée la plus puissante
du monde a été mise au point en
seulement huit ans
après trois jours d'un vol sans histoire
seulement ponctuelles par les activités
quotidiennes
l'équipage s'approche de la lutte les
seuls armstrong et aldrin prennent place
à bord du module lunaire pour la
descente mais à 900 mètres d'altitude
une alarme se déclenche houston
identifie la panne c'est l'ordinateur de
bord qui est saturé pour la survole un
dernier cratère lé 22h10 à paris lorsque
eagle l'aigle cette fausse dans la mer
de la tranquillité
cinq heures plus tard armstrong et sur
l'échelle et se prépare à sauter mais au
dernier moment ils hésitent
il veut faire un saut parfait qu'on va
retenir la phrase qu'il a préparée voilà
c'est fait le met sur la lune une
demi-heure plus tard c'est au tour de
buzz aldrin
pour moi le mérite essentiel d'apollo
fut de démontrer que l'humanité n'était
pas à jamais clouées sur terre et que
notre horizon s'étend bien au delà que
nos possibilités sont sans limites
pendant 2h30
cette mission se transforme en show
télévisé 500 lui vient de
téléspectateurs regardent abassourdi ces
images qui apporteront la gloire aux
deux astronautes
les hommes doivent suivre les robots et
s'aventurer dans les régions les plus
reculées du système solaire voilà
pourquoi j'ai fait tout mon possible
pour que nos futures navettes spatiales
accueillent à leur bord des journalistes
des enseignants et même de simples
curieux dans les places pourquoi pas se
retirer au sein sur le chemin du retour
puis expliqueront et raconteront encore
leur incroyable aventure
il semble transformer je voudrais dire
aux gens à tous les gens qui me coûte et
me regarde ce soir ceux ci
que dieu vous bénisse bonne nuit
et puis c'est le plongeon dans la
capsule au large d'hawaï
le voyage est terminé après le 11 c'est
la victoire de l'amérique et du
président nixon
c'est aussi celle du président qu'il ait
dit qu'il avait initiée mais c'est aussi
et surtout la plus fantastique aventure
spatiale et humaine de tous les temps
avec ce souci on l'a dit les américains
concrétiser donc leur supériorité
technologique sur l'urss qui ne les
rattrapera plus jamais mais à quoi ont
servi ces missions lunaires pourquoi
tant d'argent dépensé diront les
grincheuses le budget de la polo rose
était de 25 milliards de dollars
se souvient on que d'autres missions par
exemple ont suivi apollo 11 quelques
éléments de réponse avec marc
maisonneuve
quand on pense qu'ils ont l'air de
s'amuser on se trompe vitres av
et pourtant alan shepherd est le premier
golfeur sur la lune c'est le curieux
ballet des astronautes en état
d'apesanteur vite rappelé à l'ordre par
leur encombrant matériel car ils sont
littéralement là pour amener la lune la
conquête de l'espace est bien plus
qu'une victoire dans la guerre froide
c'est une succession de découvertes
scientifiques ce qui a marqué le xxème
siècle c'est l'homme sur son satellite
naturel du point de vue delà de la
technique spatiale ça a été
effectivement un succès majeur puisque
en disant il a fallu mettre au point une
fusée qu'on a fait marcher du premier
coup qui n'a jamais failli et qui a
donné donc les missions apollo que l'on
sait on envoyait douze hommes sur la
lune
douze hommes pour cette mission en deux
entre 69 et 61 un seul échec
apollo 13 missions rapt d'apollo 11
apollo 17 l'émission ont permis de
vérifier une hypothèse en partie la lune
est une bulle de la terre elle
proviendrait de la même structure
nous le savons grâce aux relevés
topographiques aux photos et surtout au
ramassage des pierres 200 kg total
observé par tous les scientifiques du
monde et elles n'ont livré qu'une infime
partie de leurs secrets
remontant à quatre milliards et demi
d'années celle ci par exemple premier
exemplaire analysé mieux une perle de
lui
lapierre de lâcher aujourd'hui sur les
douze astronautes tous largement
sexagénaire 300 morts conrad d'apollo 12
shepherd d'apollo 14 et irwin d'apollo
15 après 71 et apollo 17
le rêve d'une colonie humaine sur la
lune s'est arrêtée ce sont des robots
qui ont remplacé les hommes alors avec
nous en duplex de toulouse l'astro de
patrick baudry bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous ce soir vous souvenez vous de ceux
de votre 20 juillet 69 oh oui bien sûr
j'étais là ce pilote à l'école de l'air
et on a passé avec mes camarades la nuit
à regarder
bezannes il alunir et c'était un jour
extraordinaire enfin une nuit
extraordinaire comme pour la plupart de
ceux qui ont regardé
alors si ces vols avaient un intérêt pas
seulement politique mais aussi
scientifique on se demande un peu
pourquoi ça s'est arrêté brutalement
oui bon l'intérêt à l'époque était
surtout politique bien sûr mais je
reprendrai les ce qu'a dit neil amstrong
tout à l'heure vous savez c'était une
aventure extraordinaire
et lorsqu'on termine ce siècle on se
rend compte que c'est une mésaventure
que l'on cite toujours on ne cite pas le
plus grand bond à la bourse le voyez pas
des choses comme ça je crois que l'homme
a besoin de rêver et qu'il a besoin
d'avancer et seal cove ski qui est le
père de la cosmétique russe et mme est à
dire que la l'humanité avait pour
berceau la planète terre et qui ne
voyait pas pour quelle raison elle
resterait dans son berceau
alors là presque un petit peu
l'impression de son mieux quelquefois
maintenant c'est un petit peu des
allures de routine l'espace maintenant
on va voir des images de du dernier
moment d'émotion qu'on a connu avec
l'espace en tout cas c'est le plus fort
c'est ce petit robot qui est arrivé sur
mars tout le monde a suivi cela est ce
que c'est ça l'avenir de spatiale
m'attends à ce que c'est un maintien
robotisée sans la présence de l'homme
non bien sûr le robot ne peut faire que
des choses simples et et l'homme est
indispensable dans un environnement de
systèmes complexes et on a l'impression
que l'homme n'a plus grande utilité dans
l'espace parce qu'on ne réalise plus que
des missions autour de la terre qui sont
il est vrai sans grand intérêt et qui ne
font rien
ne font plus rêver personne n'ose
imaginer qu'on puisse aller sur mars que
l'homme puisse aller sur mars malgré les
distances qui sont très très très très
grande
bien sûr l'homme et rassure mars et il
ira certainement au cours du siècle que
va s'ouvrir au début à la fin du siècle
peu importe mais il est rare
il y aura bien sûr sur mars leur mire a
toujours aussi loin que les techniques
qu'ils maîtrisent lui permettront
d'aller c'est aussi simple que cela
et même si les grincheux ou les où les
houles et ceux qui sont toujours triste
regarde les choses différemment
c'est ce qui se passera on a besoin
d'entreprendre on a on a besoin
d'avancer on a besoin de rêver
ça s'appelle l'ambition et l'homme on
est doté même si d'autres ont d'autres
d'autre type d'ambition - qui font moins
rêver bien c'est celle ci qui prônera
toujours on ira sur mars et je leur en
donnera sur la lune très bientôt et
juste un mot en terme d'ambition on
imagine qu'il faut une ambition
politique claire comme celle qui était
affichée par le président kelly elle
n'est pas bonne est un défi vous allez
important que ça ça manque aujourd'hui
oui peut-être peut-être on cherche trop
à lancer des programmes qui dont on
détermine à l'avance la rentabilité
je crois que la science la découverte
c'est autre chose ça va bien au delà et
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui nos hommes
politiques manque du courage de lancer
des grands programmes pourtant un besoin
ce n'est pas en continuant à tourner
autour de la terre ou en lançant cette
station internationale dont on nous
rabat les oreilles qui va coûter encore
plus cher qu'apollo d'ailleurs 150
milliards de francs je sais pas si vous
imaginez ce n'est pas avec ce type de
programme que l'on avancera ni sur le
plan scientifique ni sur le plan de
toutes les retombées sur notre vie
quotidienne
il faut aller plus loin et on ira plus
loin très bientôt merci merci beaucoup
en tout cas patrick baudry puis on a
bien compris que vous êtes impatients de
partir dans l'espace est de deux de vous
lancer à la conquête de deux nouveaux
horizons oui merci merci en tout cas
revenons maintenant sur terre à
strasbourg plus précisément avec
l'élection du président du parlement
européen 20 ans après simone veil les
parlementaires européens se sont choisi
une femme comme présidente
l'udf nicole fontaine une figure connue
du parlement strasbourg élu dès le
premier tour contre mario soares pour
les socialistes arnaud boutet et carole
comme madame fontaine
taichung porcel 306 voix pour nicole
fontaine
on attendait plusieurs tours un seul
aura suffi pour obtenir la majorité
absolue
son challenger le portugais mario soares
est battu face à lui le président de
l'udf françois bayrou en bras celle qui
fut longtemps à ses côtés est numéro
deux sur sa liste lors des élections
européennes
me faire l'une des plus merveilleuses
surprise ni malice et je voudrais
vraiment vous dire je suis très très ému
et pourtant la surprise n'est pas totale
depuis quelques jours beaucoup la voyait
présidente grâce à l'accord passé entre
son groupe le ppe et les libéraux ont
négocié dans les couloirs et dans son
bureau nicole fontaine préparer déjà les
futures réformes qu'elle veut engager
avec une priorité mieux contrôler la
commission de bruxelles
rien ne sera plus comme avant la
commission j'irais pas que la commission
est sous haute surveillance ce serait
être serait pas une bonne expression
mais la commission sait parfaitement que
le parlement ne lui pardonnera rien
depuis 15 ans nicole fontaine offre
l'image d'une députée européenne assidus
et convaincu aujourd'hui elle souhaite
montrer l'exemple en direction notamment
de ses collègues français réputés pour
leur discrétion
alors question quand elle les remettre
au travail sur les bancs de l'assemblée
les français j'ai bon espoir avec
certains
aujourd'hui nicole fontaine cherchait
son chemin mais elle a gagné l'estiment
de cette grande maison le parlement et
c'est bien là l'essentiel
et ce soir l'élection de même fontaine
et salue aussi bien par jacques chirac
que par lionel jospin
parmi les dossiers qui attendent eux
nicole fontaine il y a bien sûr la
nouvelle guerre commerciale entre
l'europe et les états unis certains
produits comme le foie gras le roquefort
la moutarde ou encore les troupes
françaises seront taxés à 100%
pas question de céder a dit jean glavany
le ministre l'agriculture et d'autoriser
l'importation de boeuf aux hormones
américain
mais les professionnels protestent comme
à roquefort qui exportent 2% de sa
production globale vers les usa
christophe la rocca et jean-pierre chose
les préparations pour les états vont
partir demain chez le principal
producteur de roquefort c'est l'un des
tout derniers louent à partir pour les
états unis avant le 29 juillet après
cette date fatidique
chaque importation sera taxé à 100% un
coup dur qui ici n'est pas jugé fatal
avec 440 tonnes le marché américain ne
représente que 2% du total des ventes
mais les producteurs ne veulent pas
assumer seule une perte de 30 millions
de francs a priori il n'y a aucun
rapport entre le rock folk boeuf aux
hormones donc la communauté européenne a
pris ses dispositions les dispositions
entraînent des sanctions la communauté
doit supporter les sanctions un
raisonnement d'une logique imparable
largement partagé dans cette région où
le roquefort est l'une des rares
richesse cinq mille éleveurs alimente
les caves des industriels selon un
système traditionnel
pour eux le prix du lait est directement
indexés sur les bénéfices des ventes de
fromages
un prix qui n'a cessé de baisser depuis
dix ans les négociations le prix du lait
vont commencer à l'automne et pour la
campagne à 99,6 cette crise dure on a
bien peur que ça joue sur le fait lever
des sommes pour l'instant les
industriels ont décidé de faire le gros
dos certains vont baisser fortement
leurs prix aux états unis pour rester
sur le marché malgré la taxation
car outre atlantique un produit absent
un an des rayonnages mais trois à quatre
ans pour reprendre son la sphère des hlm
de la ville de paris au lendemain de sa
longue audition par le juge halphen jean
tiberi proteste contre sa mise en examen
qu'il juge toujours incompréhensible et
injustifiée
reportage d'olivier caroff hedhili
limbourg youssef la rénovation du
châtelet officiellement jean tiberi
était venu parler théâtre ce matin
de quoi oublier un autre genre
d'audition dans un autre genre de palais
le palais de justice de créteil jean
tiberi a passé six heures hier dans le
bureau du juge halphen mise en examen
pour complicité de trafic d'influencé
dans la sphère de l'opac à l'office hlm
le maire de paris aimerait jouer les
figurants de ce dossier de marchés
truqués
cette mise en examen est toujours pour
moi incompréhensible
je n'ai aucune autre façon régulière
selon vous pour tout à fait l'audition
était tout à fait normale et je n'en
dirai pas plus sa mise en examen jean
tiberi la doit essentiellement à cet
homme jean-luc thélème a passé six ans à
l'opac jusqu en 98 il y représentaient
les locataires en plein conseil
d'administration devant jean tiberi il a
posé des questions précises sur la
passation des marchés notamment sur le
prix du chauffage sa paire savait qu'on
avait des années manicamp importantes
d'aidés sur coup deux en moyenne et
surtout les 30 à 40% sur le chauffage et
l'eau chaude et ce marché est celui des
ascenseurs sont au coeur de l'enquêté du
juge halphen
mais jean-luc thélème se souvient
d'autres cas de surfacturation
lorsque et donc ou une simple ampoule
étaient achetés par le cabinet chargé de
gérer cette copropriété dans lequel le
pack avait une majorité de logements 90
% de logements et bien cette ampoule
était facturé plus de 6 francs alors que
le sable particulier pour lui a trouvé à
4 francs 50 au magasin à côté de chez
lui des petites dépenses aux gros marché
les anomalies étaient donc nombreux à
l'opac président de sept fils hlm le
plus grand de france depuis dix ans jean
tiberi estime qu'il n'est en rien
responsable de cette gestion contestée
berne abonnés l'ancien préfet de corse a
été entendu à huis clos pendant près de
trois heures par les membres de la
commission d' enquête sénatoriale pas de
commentaire la sortie bernard bonnet
tout comme les sénateurs sont tenus au
secret des délibérations
demain les sénateurs doivent entendre
entre autres personnalités
elisabeth guigou à l'étranger en algérie
cette grâce aux indications d'un
prisonniers islamistes repentis que la
police a fait une découverte macabre à
une vingtaine de kilomètres à l'ouest
d'alger dans la région dooley l'allèle
les enquêteurs ont retrouvé au moins dix
corps dans deux puits différents la
plupart des victimes seraient des civils
enlevés à des faux barrages routiers
reportage de jérôme bonnet et de monde
où angie rabat un islamiste repenti
purge actuellement une peine de dix ans
de prison
il a eu droit à une sortie pour guider
la police algérienne vers depuis ou sont
ensevelis de nombreux corps des victimes
du groupe armé auquel appartenait rabat
étrange collaboration entre celui qui
est considéré comme un terroriste des
policiers qui ne croient pas forcément à
son repenti nous sommes aux portes
d'alger dans ce qui fut l'un des
bastions des gia jusqu'à une grande
offensive de l'armée algérienne en 97
dont les effets dévastateurs sont encore
visibles
la police scientifique a commencé hier
les fouilles dans ces deux puits où
étaient jetés les nombreuses victimes
par exemple des civils kidnappé à des
faux barrages dès qu'ils les gorges à
quelqu'un il le jetait dans le puits que
ce soit un citoyen ou un terroriste car
ils s'entretuent est aussi entre eux il
y a eu plusieurs émirs il changeait
souvent dès qu'il y en avait un qui
était assassiné un autre le remplace et
rabat était patriotes défenseur du
village avant de prendre le maquis il
affirme que trois autres patriotes l'ont
poussé à trahir
il dit que les trois autres l'ont forcé
à partir avec eux moi je ne le crois pas
car il était armé pour se défendre s'il
n'était pas d'accord pour partir avec
eux ils ne pouvaient pas le forcer les
forces de sécurité seront quand les
excavations seront terminés combien de
corps gisent au fond des puits souvenir
d'une guérilla dont on espère toujours
la fin après le bombardement très
meurtrière qui a fait 17 morts civils en
irak selon bagdad le gouvernement
français exprime son malaise face à
cette politique des gouvernements
américain et britannique
une politique dont il comprend mal
l'object grigory pasko le journaliste
russe poursuivi pour avoir transmis des
informations secret défense aux médias
japonais a été condamnée aussitôt
amnistié un verdict accueilli avec
soulagement mais sur par son épouse
priori pas ce qu avait été arrêté en
novembre 97 après avoir révélé à la
télévision japonaise que la marine russe
déverser en mer du japon
des fûts de déchets radioactifs gilles
rabin jusqu'au bout grigory pasko a été
traité comme s'il était coupable
d'espionnage et de haute trahison après
19 mois de détention préventive et
plusieurs semaines au secret c'est
l'heure du verdict pour l'ancien
officier de marine devenu journaliste
et son épouse craint le pire car il
s'agit de l'un des deux derniers procès
monté par l'ex kgb
ce serait stupide de penser qu'ils vont
dire oui on avait tort soin de notre
pays il n'y a jamais eu un seul cas où
ce qui demande une condamnation ne
l'obtiennent surtout il s'agit du kgb à
l'entrée dans la salle d'audience du
tribunal militaire de vladivostok et à
la gêne visible des juges
on comprend pourtant que l'accusation la
plus grave la haute trahison n'a pas été
retenu et que l'ex kgb qui voulait la
tête de pasco a perdu sur l'essentiel
l'ancien capitaine et condamné à une
peine de principe de trois ans de prison
immédiatement amnistié et libéré le
crime du capitaine parce qu le voici ce
films vidéo pris sur le vif qui montre
comment la flotte russe du pacifique et
l'armée se débarrasser en mer du japon
des armements périmés et des déchets
radioactifs et chimiques
un film que grigory pasko avait remis à
la télévision japonaise nhk et qui à
l'époque en 97 avait provoqué un
scandale et une crise diplomatique entre
moscou et tokyo
à l'autre bout de la russie à saint
pétersbourg un autre ancien officier de
marine le capitaine alexandre nikitine
et poursuivez de la même façon par l'ex
kgb mais il reste lui dans la tente des
verdicts pour avoir prouvé l'existence
de véritables poubelles nucléaires
militaires au large de la presqu'île de
mourmansk
c'est une forme de puzzle macabre qui
prend forme petit à petit autour d'un
suspect numéro un
fredo stranieri il ya la police découvre
elle les restes de deux corps enterrés
près d'une ancienne boîte de nuit en
région parisienne aujourd'hui le même
scénario s'est produit dans le jardin
d'une auberge près de l'aveyron à chaque
fois il s'agissait d'anciens
propriétaires des établissements
racheter quelque temps auparavant
justement par alfredo stranieri stéphane
breitner et maxime le chien
l'histoire se répète à 800 km de
distance
cette fois ci c'est dans le jardin de
l'auberge de bez de naussac que les
gendarmes ont découvert en milieu
d'après-midi de cadavre enterré dans le
jardin
alfredo stranieri propriétaire de
l'auberge depuis quatre mois étaient
présents sur les lieux en tant que
témoin c'est lui qui avait racheté la
maison un couple d'amis en avril dernier
depuis aucune nouvelle de claude mouly
et catherine rousseau bien sûr nous ne
savons pas avec précision maintenant
compte tenu qu'il ya un certain temps
qu'ils sont enterrés là de qui il s'agit
mais ils sont extrêmement probable qu'il
s'agisse des deux personnes que nous
recherchions maintenant depuis quelques
semaines hier soir les gendarmes ont
découvert deux autres corps dans cette
discothèque de la banlieue parisienne
selon les premiers résultats de
l'autopsié il s'agit d'une femme tuée
par balle et d'un homme
c'est probablement frédéric hagman le
propriétaire de la discothèque et sa
compagne nathalie girard
même si les deux cadavres n'ont pas
encore été identifiés et là encore
apparaît le nom de stranieri en novembre
il avait conclu un contrat de location
gérance avec le couple à partir de cette
date on ne les reverra plus voici donc
alfredo stranieri désigné comme le
suspect numéro un dans ces deux affaires
à chaque fois le même scénario dans
l'aveyron comme dans l'essonne les
enquêteurs vont maintenant rechercher
s'il existe un lien entre stranieri et
ses quatre cadavres
son audition est attendue dans les
prochaines 24 heures une nouvelle
affaire de dégazage dans la méditerranée
au large de la ciotat le coupable n'a
pas été identifiée la pollution aux
hydrocarbures a été évité mais les
autorités parlent de plus en plus
d'attentats touristique jacques cardoze
et jean-françois giorgetti dès les
premières heures de la matinée les
pompiers de cassis ont dû poser des
barrages flottants 300 m de protection
au large du port et des calanques à
titre préventif car le vent devrait
repousser la pollution vers le large
une nappe d'hydrocarbures traités par la
préfecture maritime et disperser dès
l'après midi
cette fois il n'y aura donc pas de
désagrément pour les touristes
il est vrai que celui on a eu une petite
brise de terre qui a pu ramener
ce pollution au large aujourd'hui reste
quand même l'incertitude de savoir où
elle est et à quel régime devant nous
allons passer un dégazage ou nettoyage
de fond de cale doit en principe
s'effectuer dans un port une vidange qui
coûte cher par choix économiques nombre
de bâtiments préfère donc la vidange
sauvage en haute mer là où les contrôles
sont difficiles la plupart du temps
c'est que l'on découvre des nappes à la
mer dans les eaux territoriales ou hors
des eaux territoriales sans avoir à
proximité de navires susceptibles de
polluer la mer est finalement très vaste
nous avons un avion qui vole tous les
jours mais il ne peut pas bien entendu
être partout en même temps donc en
particulier la nuit la détection n'est
pas allée pas aisé l'identification
n'est pas aisé donc
nous avons un temps de retard sur le
pollueur un pollueur qui peut dormir
tranquille juridiquement il est en effet
impératif de constater l'infraction en
flagrant délit et dans le territoire
français dans la plupart du temps ceux
là ont lieu en haute mer et de nuit pour
la préfecture maritime
il est donc quasiment impossible
d'éviter ces pollutions sauvage est
toujours au large de la côte d'azur ce
sont la france l'italie et monaco qui
ont décidé de créer un sanctuaire pour
la protection des baleines et des
dauphins une zone délimitée par la
presqu'île de giens la sardaigne et le
sud de la toscane où vivent environ 1000
baleines et 25000 dauphin olivier théron
et joseph dans la pierre c'est la grande
prairie de la méditerranée c'est ici
qu'il ya le plus de plancton alors les
baleines viennent disent vrai leurs
bébés et les dauphins de se nourrir pour
tous les spécialistes c'est une zone à
protéger comme un gigantesque parc
naturel le sanctuaire permettrait à
l'italie à la france et à monaco
d'intervenir en dehors de leurs eaux
territoriales
en haute mer un far-west presque sans
loi à renforcer la lutte contre la
pollution
ensuite on va interdire de soi toutes
les prises délibéré ou toute
perturbation des cétacés
on va aussi interdire ou réglementé des
moyens de pêche qui ne sont pas
sélectifs
c'est à dire des moyens de pêche qu'ils
n'attrapent pas que des poissons
commercialisable mis quatre ans pour
signer c'est assez l'accord prévoit
aussi d'interdire ou de limiter les
courses de bateaux à grande vitesse qui
blessent les baleines ou encore les
safaris de la mer qui peuvent déranger
une maman rorqual et son petit mais
difficile sur une aussi importante
surface de faire respecter les textes
les associations de protection de
l'environnement sont sceptiques d'autant
qu'en 1992 un accord du même type avait
vu le jour sans être suivies d'effet
on avait il ya dix ans un accord qui
faisait trois pages on en a aujourd'hui
qui fait sept ou huit pages en dehors de
rentrer plus dans les détails non il n'y
a pas de choses novatrices il y a même
je trouve un recul puisque dans le
premier accord il y avait la nomination
d'une autorité compétente
je ne les ai pas retrouvé dans cet
accord aujourd'hui d'autres associations
accueillent favorablement le projet de
sanctuaire
même si de toute façon la protection
passera d'abord par l'éducation
ce qu'il faut c'est que nos enfants nos
petits enfants soient convaincus que ça
c'est un des plus gros buzz aquarium du
monde et qu'il aime alors ça ça
viendrait par la pédagogie en passant la
bonne nouvelle
en attendant la signature de l'accord et
l'évolution de la polémique baleines et
dauphins vont croiser en méditerranée à
leurs risques et périls
mais nous partons maintenant pour la
haute couture et deux défilés
prestigieux les flamboyances de
christian lacroix
et puis john galliano pour dior qui
avait choisi l'orangerie de versailles
pour cadre de ses créations sophie mais
elle est nicholl nicholl cornu langlois
et bernard connors qui connaît christian
lacroix voit que cette collection marque
une rupture
là où la rondeur l'emportait les lignes
brisées décidé et volontaires sains
cette année fut éprouvant pour le
créateur sa collection est un manifeste
on l'a dit mise à mal au sein de son
groupe le tout-puissant élevé est marche
qui a créé la croire de toute pièce il
ya plus de dix ans le couturier a choisi
d'affronter l'adversité
ça a été une année effectivement que
trés trés trés initiative que très
bousculé que plus j'ai senti comme dans
les avions des turbulences et plus envie
de m'accrocher à mon un bon fauteuil et
qu'en même temps ça a été très calme
vraiment très calme je crois que je me
suis trouvé peut-être parce qu'il a subi
la disparition d'un être cher pour la
première fois a dit lacroix je me sens
adultes ajoutant que peut-être les
personnes qui vous quittent vous aide de
là où elles sont de leur virulence
lumineuse cette collection était aussi
un hommage
quarante cinq mannequins juchée sur des
talons géant genre échasses défilent sur
un matelas d'eau devant 1200 personnes
d'abord atterré devant des humanoïdes
vêtu de cuir de stretch de fait mouche
ou sting keanu reeves dans matrix
quand soudain 20 la haute couture sous
forme de redingote en faille de l'aisne
est bouclée cuir génialement coupé
structuré contraste fulgurant entre le
romantisme de certaines robes en
dentelle perles et fait main comme des
miniatures persanes
et le futurisme agrestic détenus en
plastique avec genouillère pour relire
ce qu'est toute façon radicalement
opposé d'entrer dans le nouveau
millénaire
nostalgique ou cybernétique l'essentiel
est dosé y sauter en parachute en se
disant comme john galliano
jusque là tout va bien tout va bien je
m'en va bien tout va bien
ouais c'est facile à porter carneiro
c'est officiel la princesse caroline de
monaco vient d'accoucher d'une petite
fille alexandra c'est son quatrième
enfant mais le premier avec le prince
ernst august de hanovre
l'enfant est né dans un hôpital à 70km
de salzbourg on arrive à la fin de ce
journal je vous en rappelle les
principaux titres
le tour de france l'espagnol s carte il
s'envole dans les pyrénées mais
l'américain armstrong s'accroche il
finit quatrième et reste en jaune avec
maintenant toutes les chances de
l'emporter à paris armstrong dont le
monde révèle aujourd'hui qu'on a trouvée
dans ses urines quelques traces de
corticoïdes même s'il n'a pas pour
autant été contrôlé positif
un puzzle macabre tour d'alfredo
stranieri suspect numéro 1 après la
découverte de deux corps dans le jardin
d'une auberge en aveyron hier deux
autres cadavres ont été déterrés dans la
région parisienne dans un instant les
prévisions météo d'isabel martinez à
20h55 le temps d'une chanson présentée
par avec mitterrand à 1h vi le journal
de la nuit sera présentée par m et et
demain à 7h50 dans les 4 vérités
marie pierre farkas recevra georges
sarre le président délégué du mouvement
des citoyens à 13h vous retrouverez bien
sûr carole gaessler et rachid arhab et
moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
demain soir aux alentours de 20h bonne
soirée sur france 2 et merci
l'image